Salut ! Je suis ravis d’avoir sur notre chaîne
(Parce que, oui, c’est chez vous aussi)
– Caro! de la Carologie
– Hello !
– Je ne sais pas si vous connaissez la chaîne de la Carologie ?
« Musique de générique »
Ce que j’aime bien sur ta chaîne, c’est que c’est un fourre-tout
– Ouais ! C’est exactement ça !
J’appelle ça le foutoir.
– Ça intéresse tout le monde ; même les mecs.
La preuve, je suis abonné depuis
…début d’année, je crois
— Trop bien !
Et aujourd’hui, du coup, je propose une petite mentalisation.
L’idée : on va faire quelque chose ensemble.
Le but, c’est de te faire vivre l’expérience ;
de te bluffer en même temps
de vous bluffer aussi.
– Désolée si je regarde le retour,
j’ai pas de retour sur ma caméra.
Du coup, là, je me concentre pour regarder LÀ !
– Vous avez la sensation qu’elle regarde votre front
Depuis tout à l’heure
mais non.
– Non, je regarde le retour…
là, je regarde l’objectif !
Alors, c’est un peu freestyle. Tu sais dessiner ?
– J’adore !
– C’est vrai ? Cool !
Je te demande pas un dessin compliqué.
–D’accord
« rires »
Ça va.
Je te recommande de ne pas faire un Om̐ (ॐ)
Comme tu en as un en tatouage, un ici.
– Non, t’inquiète pas. Je vais faire un truc… h.s.
– Tu as déjà un dessin en tête ?
– hmmm…
– hmmm… Ouais !
– Ok ; ça marche !
– J’ai cru que j’allais devoir dessiner dans l’air.
– Tu veux grand ou petit calepin ?
– Petit.
– Tu veux petit ou gros feutre ?
– Gros feutre !
La fille indécise, tu sais !
« rire »
Donc, tu vas faire ton dessin
à partir du moment où je te le dirai
pas avant
– D’accord !
– Que je sois bien près
Alors, je suis désolé, je me colle un peu.
– Non, vas-y !
Cul contre cul.
J’adore !
– Exactement !
« rires »
Attends,
On pourrait penser que je regarde l’écran
Je vais virer…
Mince ! Je fais tomber la caméra.
Je vais retourner l’écran.
Pour vous, ça ne change rien.
– Je témoigne
– pour que vous ne puissiez
croire que je vois quoi que ce soit.
Ok ! On se met en place
Tu vas mettre ton feutre
à l’endroit où tu vas commencer ton dessin.
– D’accord !
C’est bon.
– Ok, je pense qu’on est à peu près là.
Tu vas faire un premier trait
Commence à le dessiner
mais lentement
Vas-y !
– Ok ?
– Continue… Tu as fini ?
– Là, j’ai fait un premier trait.
– Ok, continue.
– Je vais doucement ?
– Oui, vas jusqu’au bout de ton dessin.
– Ok. Et là je fais le dernier trait.
– P*tain…
« rires »
En fait
je vais te dire quelque chose, Caro.
Je ne sais pas ce que j’ai dessiné.
– D’accord.
– Soit je dessine très mal
et je perçois un peu mal
et du coup, ça ressemble à peu près
Soit je suis tellement à côté
que ça va être tellement drôle
– Du coup, je peux voir ton dessin ?
– Je ne vais pas te le faire voir
je vais le garder contre moi.
Je vais juste le montrer
aux abonnés, qui regardent la vidéo
On voit qu’il n’y a pas de triche
que je ne change pas de dessin.
Tu peux te retourner
Je t’enlève le feutre
Tu peux nous faire voir
ton dessin STP ?
– J’ai fait ça !
C’est une bouche.
– Ha ! C’est une bouche !
Très jolie !
Du coup, ça va
Je suis satisfait
sauf que je dessine très mal.
mais j’ai fait ça !
C’est pas mal !
– Trop bien !
Et je vous jure qu’il n’a pas mis le retour
Et quand même !
– C’est pas mal !
Mais tu comprends que je ne savais pas
ce que j’avais dessiné
une cacahuète ?
ou une pistache ?
Merci d’avoir regardé cette vidéo
J’espère que ça vous a plu
et à toi ?
– Oui, franchement !
Chapeau !
C’est stylé, ça !
Je pensai que tu allais faire un truc de m**de.
Un pâté ?! Mais non.
Ça peut être une bouche
Mais c'est une bouche,
-C'est une bouche conceptuelle mais c'est une bouche
- Sauf que tant que j'avais pas vu ton dessin, je ne savais pas que c'était une bouche.
Si vous ne connaissais pas
la chaîne Carologie
Je vous met un lien ici
et en description
Merci à vous d’avoir regardé cette vidéo
N’oubliez pas de la liker
et de vous abonner
si c’est pas déjà fait
en cliquant là.
Parce que le mental vlog
c’est une vidéo par jour
pendant un an.
du 1 janvier au 31 décembre
Donc, peu de gens ont vu toutes les vidéos
– C’est vrai !
– Rendez-vous demain à 11 heures.
Ciao !
– C’est comme ça que je dis « Au revoir ».